en este puesto electoral las filas están
atestadas millones de votantes
nigerianos están allí para elegir a su
próximo presidente también a los nuevos
diputados y senadores del país en la
actualidad todas las miradas están
puestas en el voto de los jóvenes en
Nigeria el 60% de la población tiene
menos de 25 años una nueva generación
que espera en particular oportunidades
de empleo en un país que está asolado
por la corrupción el desempleo y la
inflación estamos rezando para tener un
buen líder un buen presidente alguien
que pueda crear empleos para nosotros
los jóvenes infraestructurados Nos hemos
estancado en la misma manera de gobernar
una y otra vez queremos algo nuevo
la violencia criminal y de grupos
yihadistas agitaciones separatistas en
el sureste el territorio nigeriano está
sumergido en una crisis de seguridad
profunda heredada en parte de los años
bajo la presidencia de bujari como
explica este especialista
en el poder hemos visto cómo se ha
hundido la situación de la seguridad los
problemas existían obviamente mucho
antes de que él llegara a la presidencia
pero bujari prometió solucionar los
problemas incluido el más famoso boco
harán pero no lo ha conseguido
la violencia se ha materializado durante
la campaña está estado marcada por
ataques a comisarías y a militantes
también a candidatos locales y a las
oficinas de la comisión electoral